on passe sans les voir des églises
magnifique qui mérite qu'on ouvre la
porte pour y jeter un coup d'oeil
deux experts nous montre comment les
regarder pour le cno peine saint-esprit
de heureusement est un must c'est une
église unique en amérique parce que
c'est une église art déco
sa construction s'est terminée en 1933
du coup cet esprit c'est vraiment la
première église moderne au québec parce
que l'art déco est en général est placé
au début de la modernité en architecture
c'est une réalisation de l'architecte
montréalais joseph el jidd cr daou faut
regarder l'architecturé l'ornementation
architectural surtout les luminaires qui
sont tout à fait remarquables
ensuite deuxième chose c'est une
collection assez considérable de vitraux
de guido nincheri donc le grand vitrier
artistes de vitrail de montréal les
bancs les confessionnaux afin tout est
homogène
je deviens pas de fausse note c'est le
banc de marier le plus chic du québec
l'église anglicane st georges s'impose
pour david hanna cette haine envers un
manque de six plants dans notre
tradition anglicane pour moi saint
georges c'est le bijou de montréal
l'ambiance est médiéval mais sa
construction a été terminée en 1870 une
conception de l'architecte william tant
mieux c'est une traduction je trouve
extraordinaire de l'apogée du goût de
ces camps grande bretagne on va lever
les yeux et on va voir cette charpente
spectaculaire à double blochet qui est
tellement rare est tellement virus et
ensuite les vitraux sont extrêmement
bien rendue et plein de couleurs
les commerces de la rue sainte-catherine
qui cachait la façade de l'église unie
st-james et sa gigantesque rosas ont été
démolies en 2005
depuis on peut s'attarder au détail
permet un jeu de découvrez le nombre
d'animaux d'oiseaux qu'on voit dans ce
bar d'eau à l'intérieur
l'église est un magnifique amphithéâtre
réalisé par alexandre dunlop en 1889
quand on rentre ici on est impressionné
dans le manque de colonne ensuite
deuxième chose c'est l'aspect
amphithéâtre c'était une norme est un
théâtre et ça c'est très protestant se
forme à 13 ans du lait est vraiment
presque n'est qu'à saint james en fait
un mariage et unique saint-pierre-apôtre
est une des rares églises catholiques de
style néogothique à montréal elle fut
réalisée par victor bourgeot dans les
années 1850
aujourd'hui saint pierre apôtre et
l'église du village gai et reste unique
pour ses colonnes en pierre
est ce une église qui devait être
construite à l'européenne alors qu'elle
nous avons l'habitude de contenu des
églises en bois on a une colonne une
vraie colonnes en pierre si comme on
faisait dans l' architecture médiévale
d'ailleurs on voit qu'elle n'est pas
finie en eau le bandeau nepos culte et
les chapiteaux son post culte et puis
tout à coup s'arrête puis là on revient
aux habitudes du québec c'est du bois
avec du plâtre puis forcément de
limitation de pierre
deux églises du mérite un détour vers le
nord d'abord sainte-geneviève terminé en
1844 c'est la seule église de kamo
baillargé grand architecte québécois
dans la région de montréal
alors ça c'est beau d'un bâtiment qui
est dans un état original assez
intéressant le propre d'une église
classique néoclassique c'est de s'offrir
au regard comme un tout on aperçoit
lançant du volume de l'église qui est
pas diviser vraiment qui s'aperçoit
clairement
dans une scic l'église de la visitation
est considérée comme la plus ancienne
église de l'île de montréal
la nef et la première sacristie commencé
dans les années 1750 date du régime
français
l'invitation à montre un courant très
intéressant l'intérieur c'est une
sculpture
notre dame de la défense d'éclat
curiosité dans la petite italie avec un
peu de chance vous y croiserez le
petit-fils de guido nincheri artiste
peintre et maître vitrier abrégé en deux
âges
il reçoit des groupes et raconte que les
membres de sa famille ont servi de
modèle pour les anges
mais il explique aussi pourquoi son
grand père a dû représenter mussolini
dans la fresque au dessus du coeur